alright let's talk about the NRA and no
I'm not talking about the National Rifle
Association I'm talking about the NRA
the National Restaurant Association
which might be slightly more dangerous
believe it or not uh this is a political
lobby representing the nation's largest
food service companies and they're one
of the most powerful lobbyists on
Capitol Hill they get a lot of crazy
[ __ ] done let's take a look okay so they
have nearly fifty two thousand members
and this includes olive garden
McDonald's red lobster starbucks things
like that uh they have a PR firm
permanent company which is famous for
opposing sensible public interest and
safety laws uh their leaders are in
Fortune 500 companies and they have a
budget of 65 million dollars and they
employ 40 lobbyists okay so on its face
nothing here sounds that bad this is
just how America works but so there's a
lot of information here so you can pause
it and read it on your own but some of
the things that they've done they've
defended pink slime in burgers which
we've talked a ton about inhumane
conditions for poultry they've opposed
industry pledges to raise pigs humanely
they've opposed Paycheck Fairness Act
for waiters and waitresses Pregnancy
Discrimination Act and they blocked a
federal minimum wage increase for
restaurant employees they found
loopholes to exclude employees from the
new health care law all kinds of stuff
and and there's a lot more and I nobody
talks about this and you know we talk
about lobbying and money and politics
all the time here but I thought this was
sort of interesting because it brings it
literally to our table right the stuff
that we are putting in our body yeah the
stuff right there should we know more
about the National Restaurant
Association did you know about this
before we sent you guys the article way
uh in full disclosure I worked for olive
garden when I was in high school so you
really yeah I knew we were part of the
NRA the other day a different name
because we also associate NRA with
obviously the rifle thing or this is
their plan any like high like hiding in
plain sight right what was it it wasn't
you know the WWF used to be the World
Wrestling Federation and then the World
Wildlife Federation stepped in and then
the WWF the wrestling one became World
Wrestling Entertainment resign so should
we force this other an array to get
another name so we could all focus on
them a little understand
them and get a good look at them yeah
sure yeah wait korte move any further
what do we need to know about the
unlimited salad it's too good to be true
right a lot of calories of that thing
you know what's what you could what you
know what you can switch the salad and
you can switch the soup for free what do
you mean for what like did you get it
unlimited soup salad and breadsticks
yeah you get like one type of salad and
then it's still unlimited if you want to
switch it to a Caesar if you want to go
with the minestrone and then the chili
yeah and then the Toscana even Neil whoa
you well you know when you're here are
the Reuben reporting your family so
there you go ok uh so yes so it
shouldn't surprise us I suppose that a
lobbying that a you know an association
like this would use lobbying to do all
these horrible things but shouldn't we
know about this shouldn't we be talking
about this wise has never discussed it's
funny because we talk about these
stories like Papa John's opposing
Obamacare and saying oh [ __ ] is but
I'm finding out it doesn't we think like
oh that's do it okay that guy's not cool
but then we learned there's this whole
Lobby espousing these ideas across the
industry it's not just one one
billionaire yeah should the government
why is the government so involved in our
food is isn't that like the bigger
problem here that we've so separated
ourselves from our food source you know
Timmy and we don't do any kind of
farm-to-table stuff so then of course
you're when you have all these middlemen
matter you know putting laws in that
allow for all these chemicals and all
this other stuff that's a big question
why is the government involved in her
food it's necessary for survival you
know in the same way that it's involved
in our air and keeping it clean to both
of them but it's also involved in our
food for profit because it has a lot of
corporate interests to protect I mean
you look at the dairy industry the
subsidies that they get an agriculture
it's a it's a place where they can make
a lot of money and politicians get a lot
of money from these corporations so it
matters them yeah so money in politics
of course one of the things that I
thought was interesting is that they've
fought against lower sodium levels in
food which generally they say lower
sodium is
Ruiz is good that's why they want to
sell more food and they want their
products to be tasty oh so you're saying
that the NRA is not in it for our public
good they're in it for us to buy more of
their [ __ ] I mean are they in it with
the salt people like you know to be like
is it just is it just one big
[ __ ] I'm sure if we look further
will find that there is profit to be had
in certain areas and that that's why
it's happening what drives me crazy is
that they were fighting to keep a tipped
server wages so low and two and fighting
the minimum wage increase yeah I mean in
other countries you know like for well
for the tipping thing yeah they're
they're kind of they don't encourage
tipping or its looked upon it as more
you know like oh you don't think I was
good enough in my job yeah it's more of
a blue something you can be pried
prideful of even your your work as a
waiter yeah well speaking of that did
you guys know that YouTube is gonna
start putting a tip jar right over there
so I'm just saying if you what we're
doing here you could just it's not there
yet I don't think